I think it's an enormous disaster it's a
humanitarian and environmental
catastrophe and crisis even if there is
any dispute about who did this it is a
huge potential War crime basically
playing out in real time in front of us
these people have lived under bombing
shelling artillery and they still are
it's a constant drum roll in the
background throughout the day and now
they've got flooding massive flooding
over a huge area which is going to turn
not just environmental agricultural land
into they say deserts it's leaving
sewage debris oil there are floating
land mines here as well creating all
sorts of Hazards and of course there is
the immediate immediate humanitarian and
animal cost rescuing humans who are
stranded and rescuing animals who are
dying let me just bring in Niels who's a
professional firefighter from Germany
who's one of the very very few
foreigners who are here helping in
anything because what struck me is that
it's mostly ukrainians and not very many
large numbers of ukrainians large
numbers of smaller numbers of Ukrainian
volunteers some professionals military
and police but it's quite a small
scale rescue effort in comparison to the
huge catastrophe what are you planning
to do or hoping to do today
so I'm hoping that we can rescue many
people I don't know the exact numbers at
the moment you're waiting for
coordinations where we have to go next
we already rescued a couple of people we
also rescued animals I know we're
waiting for them for the coordination
and as a as a professional firefighter I
mean how how how
experienced are you in dealing with
these sort of conditions and how would
you describe them
I mean like I mean like this is this is
like goddess trophy what is like a huge
huge site it's a huge uh scale actually
so this scale that never happened yeah
so you've never seen anything quite this
big and what about have you been able to
work out the conditions that you're
going to have to be plunging yourself
itself in for in terms of because
they're talking about disease and
possibly an outbreak of Cholera there's
lots of sewage you can see it floating
around
this is actually what comes afterwards
at the moment we just have we just have
the evocation okay and how are you going
to do that how are you going to try
you've got you've brought you've brought
equipment
personal we have we have a bit of
equipment it's not enough we need more
boats like I see it we need also more
live jackets and other equipment for
water rescuing and it's I actually don't
know how many people are out there so we
just wait okay well good luck today
Niels and thanks for talking to us good
luck
um as you can see they're a very very
few foreign relief workers and emergency
aid workers who are here on the ground
right at the epicenter if you like of
the flooding and I think there's a
growing need and concern that the world
just isn't listening and helping right
now